mep's discussed the commission's track
record over the last 12 months with
president ursula fonder lion the
importance of unity during crises
european values and youth took center
stage during the debate
the taliban have returned to power in
afghanistan after nearly 20 years of war
meps discussed the humanitarian
situation and how to help afghan asylum
seekers especially women and children
parliament voted to simplify access to
the eu job market for highly skilled
foreign workers like nurses and computer
programmers
to come and work in the eu they'll now
need a six-month contract instead of the
previous one-year contract
meps examined attacks on media freedom
and the rule of law in poland and called
on the country to uphold media pluralism
poland is ranked 64th out of 179
in the world press freedom index
parliament debated lgbt iq
discrimination in the eu it said
same-sex couples should enjoy the same
rights across all eu countries currently
21 member states recognize the unions of
lgbt iq couples
[Music]
you